Now there are alternatives to implementing [UNKNOWN] prefixes match with
a try. One could start with a content addressable memory or
a CAM. Now a CAM is a hardware base route
look up where the input is a tag and the output
is a value. So, for example, the tag might be
an address and the value might be the output port. Now,
the CAM really only supports exact match but it is an
O1. There is something called a Ternery CAM, where isntead of
exact matching In the tag, you can have 0, 1, or don't care,
or a star. The ternary CAM and in particular its support for a wild
card permits an implementation of longest prefix
match. One can thus have multiple matching
entries, but prioritize the match according to
the longest prefix in the ternary CAM.